January 6 comes along and we talk about
like who let those people into that door
like who who hit the magnetic unlock and
like let those people walk in from the
inside and now we're seeing because of
January 6 the populace right and the
populace left are at odds it's as if
division was sewn by whom I don't know
but for some reason because of this
event that happened where people were
let into that freaking building by some
people now there's now we have
Congressional division which didn't seem
similar with Occupy Wall Street we were
all there together to elaborate on that
talk about the FED selection you talked
about this a year ago the January 6th we
we already know based on The
Whistleblower interviews that we've done
that there were federal agents and
federal assets that were on the ground
that day and what we don't know is the
extent to which any of those assets or
agents increase the level of criminal
Acuity coordinated with one another or
purposefully entrapped folks who were
otherwise not wanting to hurt anyone or
violate any law in some sort of
technical violence relation of
trespassing or crossing some barrier
that had existed hours earlier but that
had been taken down and
it's noteworthy to me that it's been the
Department of Justice fighting tooth and
nail against the release of a lot of the
documentary evidence that would answer
these questions and who was raps
rayaps is an is the only person involved
in January 6 that Adam kinsinger will
continuously defend isn't that something
and why I mean I think a lot of people
have assumptions he's somehow connected
with FEDS or he may be testified or
something well I just don't there's no
rational explanation for how this guy is
sending out message saying he
orchestrated the activity is at every
critical point he's like the Forest Gump
of the January 6th string of events
right and then when you're able to
isolate the people that are pulled off
of the FBI's Most Wanted lists and the
people who you know seem to be
encouraging others and moving others
that like it's like re you know Ray Epps
did nothing so they'll go and like raid
the home of some like couple in Homer
Alaska because they think they have
Nancy Pelosi's laptop but this guy who's
at the center of the action it's like
nothing to see here so you know I I am
troubled by the disparate treatment that
Epps gets compared to like some you know
grandmother that wandered past a
barricade that then is facing some
intense criminal process from doj I'm
concerned that those people in detention
are becoming radicalized just by being
forgotten and left to rot like do you
know what the status is of these people
that have been in prison well we've
gotten
varying reports on that and not nearly
enough information and a lot of them
have been deprived of just like basic
civil rights when it comes to the
adversarial judicial process one thing
I'm investigating right now is the
extent to which the public defenders
that were assigned to a lot of these
folks like hated them and wanted the
book thrown at them and were posting on
social media and texting their friends
you know about the the nature of those
proceedings so that's a big area of
concern for me how they were treated in
prison uh and in jail in the DC jail in
particular I went there I mean it was
pretty crazy I went there and they were
like locked us out of being able to do
an inspection and that's unprecedented
for a member of Congress to not have the
ability to inspect a facility that is
under the control of the federal
government at some level could you go to
Guantanamo when that was open is it
still still could yeah if you got if you
got the plane we could go tonight that's
hardcore get an authentic mojito oh I'm
so into it have you been there before I
don't want to go to gitmo you crazy
you ever see the meme that said
waterboarding at Guantanamo Bay sounds
really fun if you don't know what it is
yeah horrible
yeah no thank you what are you trying to
set me up here Ian yeah man bring your
camera I don't know are you allowed to
bring a camera inside there there's a
number of these cases where people were
engaged in journalism and are facing
charges that are more kin to
Insurrection like people who are there
trying to film and capture the event and
then you know are getting multi-year
prison sentences it's just like there's
been there's been 950 people charged so
far but the doj is saying that the
investigation is far from over and
recently through a a congressional bill
they even got more funding and they're
saying that they're going to be doubling
the amount of people that they already
arrested
um and and talk about how these
specialized units that have FBI CIA that
were targeted at extremism in you know
Afghanistan Iraq Yemen you know all over
the world that now those very same teams
and those very same tools and those very
same National Security authorities are
exclusively being turned inward you know
to instead instead of finding you know
somebody that's building a bomb to blow
up an embassy abroad they're like you
know analyzing what some guy who lives
in his mom's basement is putting on his
blog that's read by tens of people and
then the and that now after they were
turned inward as a result of this
Omnibus spending legislation they are
flooded with cash I mean just so much
money that is now in the hands of these
people who wake up every day saying you
know how can I go find a white
supremacist extremist to hunt down and
you know if if you create an industry of
witch Hunters right like you're going to
find more witches like even if they're
not actually witches and as you
mentioned in the beginning of this
broadcast this was originally created
this industry was created by George W
bush it was created by the Republicans
right after 9 11 passing the Patriot Act
allowing Homeland Security to do
whatever they want allowed allowing the
TSA to touch you wherever they wanted to
and and I think this is why there needs
to be a bigger call out of this old
Republican guard of these neocons that
created this situation that's literally
being turned around and used against the
American people the war on terror is now
the war on America and it's the
intelligence it's the intelligence
agencies waging it against American
citizens we have to have the guts to
repeal those authorities and the thing
is anytime you get any momentum behind
any effort to do that you get the
neoconservatives running in saying well
you're going to be the reason there's
another 911. and then people fold yeah
oh my gosh sounds like a threat more
than anything else yeah well it just it
is a way to test people's will and the
will often does not rise to the occasion
that's why these authorities don't get
curtailed
purely because the people are afraid
that they'll be become I mean honestly I
could see why because if something did
happen then they might feel guilt but
like uh all right this is gonna take
another couple hours to talk about I
don't think we're gonna be able to
finish this one right now all right do
you do you repeal the Patriot Act well
do you have the power to actually put a
stop to this j6 nonsense
unilaterally no the house won't have the
power to do that uh I do believe that
substantial elements in the National
Security apparatus and these these
prosecutions need to be defunded do I
think there's a critical mass of
Republicans who are willing to shut down
the government over it no but we have to
go make our case and and the thing we
got to do is like build the deterrent
against it like a lot of these folks in
for all their tough talk and for all
they're willing to do when they have
anonymity when you drag them before the
country and ask them tough questions as
I've done with some of the leading
figures in the National Security State
before the Judiciary Committee they
don't like that too much and when you do
it to a few of them the rest of them get
adrift and see that and you know that
works to a point but it it pales when
you compare it to these Exquisite
authorities that have been turned Inward
and then the extreme resourcing of them
that we have just seen so we need like a
we need the population to speak up and
start making noise about repealing the
Patriot Act I think I think that that
the patriarch was a terrible mistake for
our country and I would I would advocate
for its repeal are there things so
esoteric you know how do you convince
you know I'll put it this way we were
talking earlier about how you mentioned
he and Dave Smith's thing that if you
want to see who we're going to go up
against next look at who we're funding
now
we fund Ukraine we fund as of in 20
years we may be fighting them like we
did with the mujah Deen and then the
Taliban Al-Qaeda et cetera Afghanistan
but the kids who vote in favor of those
Wars the people right now the young
people who are liberals who are voting
for you know this policy weren't alive
when these when we were funding these
these groups right like I think I was a
baby when the muja Deen stuff was
happening and so then I'm 20 years old I
vote you know I was 18 I don't hold it
was I vote for Obama and then he's just
continuing this cycle of war against who
we had just been funding with Ukraine
give it 20 years some young person is
going to be like gotta vote Democrat
they're the ones who are fighting
against these evil Nazis the difference
they're the ones who funded it that's
the good thing though now is there's so
much media on this that it may be
Unforgettable in the Consciousness I
mean obviously there's being manipulated
to show you one or the other you know
way of looking at the situation but
people that are six may be very well
aware of what's happening in Ukraine
when they're 18. as opposed to in Iraq
2003 there's no internet video so or
very little well in the 90s there wasn't
I mean other than maybe Pat Buchanan and
a few of his buddies there wasn't a a an
anti-war segment of the political right
with any actual power right and I think
that it's because the millennial
generation has grown weary of this I
mean all of our lives our country has
been in some state of low yield war and
we see the people come back with broken
Limbs and broken hearts and broken Minds
we see the effect on marriages the drug
abuse the suicide and we start to see
the real cost of it and now on the right
there are people willing to ask tough
questions about these things and and
that scrutiny just didn't exist on a lot
of these other Misadventures if only we
would have listened to Ron Paul when
when you were young you still can when
uh when like the Patriot Act was getting
voted on stuff were you like a young
conservative yeah I think I I adhered to
a lot of the kind of Republican thinking
on those things I I thought Bush was a
great president initially and then you
know as I as I started to see in my
heavily military Community the impacts
of these wars I just thought like man
like trading a bunch of sand dunes
around in Iraq like isn't worth like
Chris's dad not having legs wow you know
and you see that over and over and it
impacts you and not only that these
interventions also created more future
conflicts it not only allowed Iran to
have more of a sphere of influence in
the region but because we we went in
there and overthrew the government we
created Isis in so many different ways
is by incentivizing that group to start
up there and to also hand over a lot of
American Military technology and and
weapons right directly into their hands
giving us a new enemy to fight and use
them as ponzo to overthrow something I
told Trump is that it was all no matter
what the policy area was it was always
the neocons that stabbed him in the
background you know if you just wanted
to take like a crude uh way to triage
like the people that stabbed him in the
back they were part of his own
Administration it was always the neocons
why did you think he kept coming to them
asking them for hugs all the time and
giving them all these lucrative
positions of power I want to ask
something for the audience a lot of
people are asking about the ATF passing
a new role on pistol braces do you see
this they're they're gonna they're
saying they're NFA items now basically
they're banning them I'm curious uh
abolish the ATF what do you think yeah I
mean Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms is
just what we call a good Saturday night
in my district or it should be the name
of a store or not you know an agency no
I mean it there is a deep State at the
ATF I mean no doubt and during the Trump
Administration and it was actually
pretty bad there a lot of the rules that
they were passing were converting people
into criminals who had no intention of
violating the law whatsoever
I honestly don't even think that you
should be able to like seriously debate
gun legislation if you're not from an
SEC State you know when I see like the
northeasterners you know get all worked
up and they don't know anything about
Firearms they haven't used Firearms they
haven't stored Firearms it's quite
comical to see like David sicilini from
Rhode Island or you know was it they
Thomas Massey asked Jerry Nadler of New
York like what does the AR stand for in
AR-15 and Nadler said assault rifles
what's SEC States like the Southeastern
Conference you know Georgia Florida
Mississippi Tennessee Arkansas well you
got New Hampshire up there too in New
Hampshire and West Virginia West
Virginia's constitutional carry thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time